i couldn't help myself i couldn't i just
please you have to understand
trust me i definitely understand
hey guys pete here today i'm going to do
a recap of the first season of dexter
i'm going to talk about everything that
happens in this introduction to the
series main character that includes the
ending so there will be spoilers if you
haven't seen the season but even though
this is a re-watch recap i won't be
directly spoiling anything that happens
in future seasons with that out of the
way let's get started in season 1 you
meet dexter and learn rather quickly who
he is and what makes him tick at the
beginning of the series he is a
dedicated serial killer you get the
impression that this normal looking guy
who's in his early 30s this is really
what his existence revolves around over
the course of the season you realize
he's compelled to kill still it isn't
completely dark he's actually a quite
likable character considering they
achieve this in various ways first he's
self-aware and you're given insight into
his thinking through a voice-over this
makes you feel like you're in on it
because you know the secrets that the
rest of the characters are missing it
also removes some of the mystery and it
makes it feel alright to just enjoy this
curious and amusing character the other
thing they do and this works a lot
better than it sounds when you say it
out loud dexter is a serial killer that
only kills other killers he deals with
and manages his compulsion by following
the code of harry a set of guidelines
that include things like don't get
caught and blend in socially but more
importantly things like never kill an
innocent and only target killers that
have escaped justice harry was dexter's
adoptive father who you see as he works
through issues in his mind when dexter
has to make a difficult decision he
remembers the things that harry taught
him before he died and therefore he's a
regular character you learn that harry
was a police officer who was all too
familiar with the idea that some people
got away with doing horrible things they
slipped through the cracks and we see
right in the pilot that he recognizes at
an early age there's something different
about dexter when he discovers the grave
of their neighbor's missing dog buddy
the code doesn't absolve him but it does
make things more interesting because in
his own mind he thinks he's being
righteous he thinks he needs to kill
this was backed up by harry in his
formative years and this is more
palatable because it's delivered through
this framework of delivering justice for
people who got away with murder you
don't like what he does but you tend to
minimize that because you like the
character and his first on-screen kill
of michael donovan pastor choir master
pedophile serial killer is a perfect
example of this nobody would argue that
this guy being stopped from what he's
doing is some kind of tragedy and so
dexter's there to take care of it in the
second killing he does we get a better
idea into how his process works when he
goes after jamie jaworski who was a
sexual sadist that kidnapped raped and
killed his victim in a snuff film only
to get off when he was caught because of
a bad search warrant you see dexter
follow him you see him get proof of his
guilt and then you see how he sets up
the kill room and how things play out
and we see that continue with his third
kill of matt chambers who's a
remorseless drunk driver who kills
someone and gets away with it it's
established that dex is careful elusive
and he feels justified in his choice of
victims part of how he discovers those
is from his day job as a forensic
specialist he's a blood spatter expert
at miami metro police department where
he comes off as being a little odd but
most of his co-workers write this off as
him being a lab geek in season one we
also meet the cast regulars at the
station fellow forensic specialist vince
masuka detective angel batista sergeant
james stokes and lieutenant maria
laguerta of those dogs is the only one
who thinks there's something wrong with
dexter and we see his suspicions
escalate throughout the first
season the main characters are rounded
out with dex's adoptive sister deborah
morgan and his girlfriend rita deb is
pretty much the opposite of dexter
personality wise she swears a lot she's
direct sometimes emotional but she
actually does take her job as a police
officer seriously following in harry's
footsteps
in season one she gets transferred out
of vice and into homicide and this
creates a situation where she's
sometimes pursuing the same criminals as
her brother but the siblings have
different ideas of how justice should be
served
dexter's relationship with rita starts
out just as a way to help him fit in
she's a single mother of two whose
abusive ex-husband's in prison and part
of why he thinks their relationship
works is because she's as damaged as he
is beyond introducing you to dexter and
the other main characters the first
season also lays the groundwork for the
structure the show follows throughout
its early seasons there are kills of the
week like the three i mentioned earlier
plus jorge and victoria castillo that
i'll come back to and the therapist
emmett meridian the kills of the week
are all characters that generally appear
in one episode dexter researches them
pursues them and he does his thing
there's also side stories with the other
characters sometimes those are tied in
with dexter and sometimes they're not
there's also usually a story about
dexter's personal life and then there's
the season's main adversary or
antagonist that presents a sort of
existential threat that stretches out
over all the episodes for the side
stories in season one doakes is caught
up in an investigation where an
undercover cop and his wife both end up
dead it comes out that james was having
an affair with the wife who was waiting
for her husband to finish his undercover
assignment before getting a divorce this
leads to dokes being on the radar of the
cartel boss who ordered their murders
and the victim's brother who's also a
cop is giving him trouble about the
affair it all wraps up with james
getting kidnapped by the drug lord and
then that turns out to be a trap set by
the brother who swoops in to make an
arrest also dokes gets involved with a
haitian man who he sees walking across
the bridge he jumps out of the car and
kills him before angel catches up doke
says the victim shot first but angel
doesn't believe that's how it went down
based on what he heard he eventually
decides to tell the truth after being
pushed by internal affairs only to find
out that they dropped the case in the
end this establishes that angel is more
or less an honest cop and that dokes has
a secret past that laguerta and angel
think might be related to the cia or
black ops because of how it played out
beyond that angel is separated from his
wife he had an affair and he told her
about it because of that honesty and
eventually gets a divorce deb struggles
to make her way in the homicide unit and
legueta clearly doesn't like her and
tries to hold her back maria has her own
problems with captain matthews who views
her as a threat and after some political
maneuvering that goes back and forth he
ends up replacing her in his personal
relationships dex works through his
intimacy issues with rita and once their
relationship starts to be somewhat
normal her ex-husband gets released
early from prison paul who was
physically abusive and refused to sign
divorce papers tries to reconcile with
rita who isn't interested he lays it on
heavy with the kids despite him being an
awful person he does seem to love them
rita grants him supervised weekly visits
in exchange for the divorce but he
eventually shows up her house drunk one
night and tries to force himself on her
she hits him with a bat in self-defense
and he manages to turn that around
filing charges for assault in an effort
to win custody this all proves to be
annoying for dexter he ends up getting
involved knocking paul out with a frying
pan in rita's kitchen after they have
some words and then he takes him back to
his room and sets him up by injecting
him with heroin so that he'll violate
his parole in prison paul has no idea
how he got there he suspects that
dexter's involved but he can't remember
how things happened and he realizes that
he was missing a shoe when he got
arrested he pesters rita by phone he's
trying to implicate dexter and she
pretty much ignores him because their
relationship is going really well by the
end of the season though she finds the
shoe and is forced to think that dex
might have been involved in what
happened
while all of this is going on the ice
truck killer case is looming over the
miami metro police department he's a
serial killer that dismembers the bodies
of his victims after draining their
blood this leaves an impression on all
the responders at the crime scene at a
motel in the pilot episode including
dexter the ammo matches two previous
victims that were discovered in nearby
broward county and the discovery of
another in the first episode makes it
pretty clear that the crimes are related
and that they're the work of a serial
killer while talking with deb who
mentions that the body parts were cold
at the last crime scene dexter guesses
he might be using a refrigerated truck
and when this turns out to be the case
he earns the name the ice truck killer
things get personal with the case when
dexter sees a refrigerated truck follows
it only to get the head of one of the
victims tossed at his car later when he
returns to his apartment he finds the
head of a doll stuck on his refrigerator
inside he discovers the rest of the doll
cut up in the same way that the victims
were at the crime scenes as the
investigation continues it has effects
on the department like deb finding the
truck and that getting her promoted to
homicide a couple of wrong suspects are
named as the killer and that sets off
the tensions between the captain and
legueta and this situation establishes
the precedent of dexter wanting to solve
the case for his own selfish reasons
before the police get a chance to make
an arrest the first suspect that the
department focuses on that turns out to
be innocent is a security guard named
tony tucci he was forced to place body
parts of a victim at the ice rink he
worked at while it was all caught on
camera later his body parts started
showing up at different locations in
miami that only dexter knew were tied to
his childhood memories that the ice
truck killer learned about from looking
at photos inside of his apartment dex is
lured to an old closed down hospital
where he finds tony who's missing those
body parts but still alive he's
presented on a kill table with knives at
the ready but dexter decides not to kill
him because he doesn't fit the criteria
of the code instead he tips off deb
anonymously and she's able to rescue him
and get him to a hospital there she
meets his prosthetist rudy cooper who
over time sweeps her off her feet as
their relationship develops it becomes
pretty clear that he's really interested
in getting close to dexter but he does a
good job of keeping that fact from her
and she falls in love with him in the
same episode that she makes the
relationship public with her co-workers
rudy is revealed to be the ice truck
killer when you see him alone in his
apartment that has the walk-in freezer
by this time he's done a lot in the way
of communicating with dexter killer to
killer the head on the truck the dolls
the body parts and locations from his
photos leaving tony for an easy kill
messages on craigslist and he even
resurfaced the body of dex's victim
valerie castillo which led to a lot of
tension at work when a young witness who
was hiding in the trunk of a car was
discovered during the investigation you
can see that the ice truck killer is
trying to connect with dexter knowing
full well that he's a serial killer too
and things all come together when he
gets a letter saying that his biological
father has died and left him a house
this leads to everyone coming together
and dexter learning that harry lied to
him about his real parents being dead he
had already started to remember what
happened when he was a kid during the
therapy sessions that he was doing to
investigate emmett meridian and now rudy
has injected himself into his life as
someone he can talk to you also find out
that he killed the biological dad and
made it look like a heart attack to set
things in motion this is followed up by
a staged crime scene at a hotel where
there aren't any bodies but it's filled
with the blood of at least five people
when dex is sent in first he has a panic
attack and is unable to work the scene
after collapsing deb makes the
connection that the blood is from the
ice truck killer's victims after talking
to an amputee at a club angel has a
hunch that there's a connection to the
case he goes to ask rudy about the
fetish and that leads to him getting
stabbed
later dexter decides to confront his
fear after being encouraged by rudy and
when he goes back to the hotel room he
relives his suppressed memory he
remembers that he watched his mother's
brutal murder when he was 3 years old
this sets him on a path to understand
his past he finds out his mother was
working as a police informant who was
killed but can't find any mention about
her leaving behind a kid in the news
reports while the investigation is
starting to close in on rudy deb who's
fully in love finds out through decks
that he's thinking of proposing and we
also see that doakes is starting to
wonder if dexter might be connected to
the case
after finding blood from the attacker on
angel's shirt and testing it dexter
learns that rudy is the ice truck killer
he tries to keep deb away from him but
she's already gone to see him on a yacht
that he chartered where he proposes and
she accepts only to be drugged with a
celebratory glass of champagne and from
there she becomes his prisoner dexter
frantically tries to find her and
discovers that rudy's left clues for him
to follow the police department is able
to find out his true identity and they
find his apartment in kill room a clue
there leads dex to his mother's home
where he experiences a memory from
childhood rudy is there too he's waiting
for him and it's revealed that he's his
biological brother who was also there
when his mother died in the shipping
container his real name is brian moser
and he tells dex about his past harry
only saved dexter because he thought he
was young enough to block it out his
older brother was committed to a mental
hospital he was pleasantly surprised
when he tracked down his brother and
learned that they are the same and now
he wants them to be together he accepts
dexter as he is and says that they can
be free to be themselves and to kill
together the only thing that he needs is
for dex to kill deb to get her out of
the picture faced with a tough decision
dexter struggles but ultimately chooses
deb and brian initially escapes as he
turns on him and the police arrive later
he sets up a trap at his apartment and
catches his brother when he arrives to
finish deb off in an emotional send-off
dexter kills his brother in his own kill
room making it look like a suicide the
police are fooled and the ice truck
killer case comes to a close
when we meet dexter at the beginning of
the season based on his own desires he
had a pretty good thing going he's been
able to satisfy his dark passenger into
his 30s 10 years after harry passed away
he was able to keep this part of him a
secret and it was all built on the
foundation of harry's code as dexter
starts to remember his mother's death
and begins to realize that harry kept
information from him he begins to
question everything you see him struggle
with his reality throughout season one
at one point he decides not to kill
jeremy downes after learning about him
being raped by his victim and they have
a conversation in jail after jeremy
kills again the idea of him doing it
just because he wanted to feel something
and dexter understanding that it calls
into question the idea of killing being
justified as simply taking out the trash
it shows that dexter also does it
because he gets something from it he
gets off on it and jeremy's choosing
suicide is an example of a different
path while he tells himself that what
he's doing is righteous he actively
misleads everyone around him and only
recognizes this as a problem that he
mostly justifies away when he hurts
deborah rita in the process in the
beginning of the season he doesn't think
he has feelings and believes the only
way he can survive is to rely on the
code since he has a secret life he can't
confide in anyone when he has a dilemma
and this is why he manifests harry in
his mind to try to work everything out
himself so by the end what brian offered
him was what he truly wanted someone he
could be himself around and someone that
would accept that he had to kill when he
killed his brother he lost something
real and proved that he does have
feelings by choosing deb and mourning
brian at the end he imagines people
celebrating him for it and even being
thankful for his other kills in that
he's making the world a better place as
a result deep down though he knows that
they would also recognize the brutality
in his form of justice and would likely
think of him as a monster if they knew
the truth by the time everything is
wrapped up he's able to keep his secret
the police have their man and his
adoptive sister is safe things can
mostly return to normal unfortunately on
her way to take out the trash rita
notices paul's shoe right where he said
it would be dexter sees that doakes is
now following him because he knows he
has something to hide and there's no one
left alive that can handle his truth he
learned a lot about himself in the first
season he revealed a lot about his
childhood and how he became what he is
but it served to make him question his
beliefs and that seems like the perfect
place to leave things
please like this video if you enjoyed it
please subscribe to my channel if you
haven't already be sure to check back
for more dexter videos and thanks for
watching i'll talk to you soon